[Music]
james is with us in chicago hi james
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you sir i appreciate that i get to
talk to both of you gentlemen it's an
honor sure how can we help
well
my wife and i have four kids they are
about eight five
three and 18 months
and we're trying to save up for our
first home and we're struggling to make
progress with regards to a down payment
that would uh get us within that 15-year
mortgage quarter take-home pay
boundary for our first home purchase are
you out of debt
hello
james
i'm here are you out of debt
yes we are out of debt completely okay
and you have your emergency fund in
place
yes sir and your household income is
what
uh we clear about 6 200 a month after
taxes on average okay right
so
did you pay off some debt already
yes sir we paid off about a hundred ten
thousand uh and we got completely out of
debt how long did that take
that
about five years
okay so you're saving at a rate of about
twenty thousand dollars a year or you
were reducing debt at a rate of about
twenty thousand dollars a year
yes and part of that was selling off
some cars and vehicles uh some
uh
we had some gifts that enabled us to
clear some more debt so it wasn't uh
just our personal income that paid off
and got us out of debt but
at this point we can squeeze maximum
eight hundred dollars a month out of our
out of our budget
you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year
and you can't find 10 grand
you're squeezing to get 10 grand i'm i'm
really confused
are you doing a written budget
yes sir every dollar has a name and both
of you are agreeing to it
yes sir absolutely we've been doing it
faithfully that's how that's how we got
out of debt and that's that's how we're
living um where is all your money going
then since you know
so we have a 2 000 rent payment
and then we have
we had 550 a month for school
the rest of it is basic living expenses
we live
in illinois
so our gas is a little bit higher
we spend about 900 a month on groceries
trying to think through what other
perhaps out of the ordinary expenses we
might have
but those are those are the main things
we have to spend about 400 a month on on
gas we've got a minivan and i drive a
four cylinder
but
yeah that's that's more or less
where we're at we do a budget and we're
largely faithful to stick to it and
adjust accordingly if something
doesn't go right
okay
all right and so overall what's your
question
i need to i need a little bit of
direction on what i could do to increase
my income without burning my family out
i said we've got four little kids
my wife does work part-time she's the
director of worship at our church and
i just um
i i don't know how to
what i got to do to accelerate the uh
what do you do for a little bit
i own a window cleaning business we do
commercial and residential window
cleaning okay
and are you a one-man gang you got some
employees how big is your your operation
uh i am a one-man band and um
that's not the way it had always been uh
because our expenses have gone up for
our for our personal lives uh
i haven't
i haven't felt that we could afford to
hire an employee just yet to help
lighten the load and yeah but the issue
for you is
increasing your client base that
includes that increases your revenue so
are you full are you maxed out as to
what you can do as far as window
cleaning
yeah just about i could maybe squeeze in
another five hours but i'm cranking out
50 55 hours and uh
you know we
uh
you could do more if you had some help
so the help would pay for itself it's
you're acting like help is a net cost
employees you should always make more
employees make more own employees than
they cost you that's how business works
yes yes that's correct however if i uh
my concern is that if i hire somebody
that's a
for a temporary season no no less uh
i would take a substantial dip in my
personal take-home pay
um because we're like i said we're
living on a pretty well okay
are you a seasonal business
sort of about a third of our revenue is
seasonal uh
well then this is so here's the deal
here's what i hear on you i hear all
these limitations
i i hear roadblock after roadblock after
roadblock and i i don't see the
roadblocks so let me give you a really
practical example if you are seasonal i
talk to people all the time that are
killing it in seasonal businesses and
they hire seasonal help they pay them
very very well
and so i don't think that's a limitation
i think you're creating something in
your head if you paid somebody 40 000
seasonally to help you and you made
another 100
that'd be okay yeah and then what can
you do in the off season
that is uh run the other 67 of the
revenue yeah plus what utility can you
bring to the table that's similar to
cleaning windows but it's a service
that's not seasonal you have skill and
you have experience that can be
leveraged to make more money in the off
season this is a function of you
deciding how important this is and get
after it i think the answer to your
question in other words is to grow your
business yeah and you grow your top line
revenue
by growing the capacity of the business
the only way to do that is to add some
help
and that's why we call them help because
they help
and um
uh you know the quote hired help thing
you know there are people hired to help
you and i've you know they've become
part of your team they become friends
it's a small business it's a family
business it's a wonderful environment
for someone but i mean you could pay
somebody pretty well
out of the extra money that you're able
to have come in because you were able to
expand your capacity
i mean if you could clean
uh
40 30 more houses
windows uh because you had one more
person on your team and you were just
that much faster because of that
i don't think you're going to get to 50
more
but you probably could get to 30 to 40
percent more and so you move from
the top line of 100k to a you know a top
line of
150
or whatever and you pay the guy 30 or
40. i mean it's it's
doable dave i think there's a follow-up
that i think a lot of our listeners
would would benefit from and you can
speak to this very uniquely
there is some
fear that is really holding him back
there this idea that employees are so
expensive and and the way you come at so
many things on the show is let's just
look at the math so for a small business
person who feels like they're the chief
everything officer and they can't grow
because they can't afford to hire
somebody what's the math process they
need to walk through real math and go
okay how i can actually walk this out
and see that it's not the big scary
monster under the bed what would you
recommend they do well there's two kinds
of team members you had
ones that are fixed expense
and uh save you money because they free
you up
for instance i hired a personal
assistant years ago which meant i didn't
have to do all the documentation and all
the other stuff which meant i could be
doing something that made money so it
increased my ability my ability to make
money because i didn't have to do some
of the stuff okay so i offloaded some
things the other type of person is a
person who directly impacts revenue
that's the easiest one to hire that's
right because you know you're going to
cost me x and you're going to make y
and if you don't make y then you're not
going to cost me x because i can't keep
you
and so we're going to have to have the
first guy i hired russ carroll
we brought him in he was here for 20
years he's retired from here he's a
wonderful friend i told russ i said you
know he was going to do financial
coaching financial counseling and i said
i we need to get some financial
counseling in here or your kids are
going to be skinny
you know this was the conversation we
had right and so
we had you know because i can't pay you
except we get more money in here to pay
you with dude because there ain't no
money here i mean we we didn't have
financial peace we were teaching
financial peace but we didn't have
financial fees you know and so
that's the thing and so we just had to
work through that and and it worked out
obviously because russ was here for 20
years but you're right it is scary but
the easiest one to have to add is one
that adds more revenue than they cost
immediately